why do you think our partners are
fighting this project
do you think they want to please us no
they are simply trying
to look after their own national
interests
that's plain and simple and i think this
project has to be completed
especially i
american administration the u.s
administration says that it wants
to build good relations with its primary
partners in europe
and how can you build good partners
with your partners while disregarding
their interests
that would be nonsensical
moreover this gas is the cleanest source
of energy in the world
and i'll tell you why
you know when this fracking is used
around 70 more than 70 of american gas
is produced via fracking whereas
gas prompt only produces 11 but
the gas coming for not stream 2 does not
use any fracking to produce
and from the environmental point of view
fracking
as a truly catastrophic type of
production because
dozens and hundreds of tons of chemical
substances are pumped
into the ground and it deals direct
damage to the environment everyone is
talking about the economy
and the environment and here you have a
flagrant example of how it's happening
when fracking is
you